one
and you're live chairman thank you good
evening and welcome to the central area
planning committee
meeting on wednesday the 21st of april
2021.
my name is councillor michael edwards
and i'm the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect
on the 4th of april 2020 in response to
the covid19 pandemic
please can i ask everyone present in
this meeting to ensure your camera
remains on
where broadband permits and your
microphone remote remains muted when not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up
hands up function of the meeting to
indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time members are reminded
apart from points of order or indicating
that you must leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purposes
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure your
reference
a page or paragraph number and keep your
contributions as clear and concise
as possible when invited to speak please
ensure
you turn on your microphone now if i may
ask officers taking part in the meeting
to introduce themselves
starting with matt lee
good evening members i'm matt lee lead
specialist place and chief plan officer
modern district council
thank you
good evening members i'm michael johnson
lead specialist development management
thank you
good evening i'm louise staplehurst and
i'm a specialist in development
management
thank you chairman thank you good
evening members bernice casey clark to
this evening's committee thank you
chairman
thank you are there any other officers
present
no chairman thank you um before i call
on the clock to take the roll call of
committee members can i ask those
counselors in attendance to introduce
introduce themselves please hello
my name is uh councillor nick skeens
from burnham and i'm in attendance
thank you chairman uh council mark
durham just in attendance thank you
thank you very much can i now
ask you to carry out a roll call of
members to confirm who is in attendance
thank you
thank you chairman members as always i
will call your names in alphabetical
order starting with counselor ms phil
prison thank you cancer edwards
present council heard
good evening everyone i'm present thank
you councillor lagan
what are you getting everybody on
present counselor maze
uh good evening barna thank you
councillor morris
councillor morris
councillor nunn
yes uh good evening bernard good evening
uh members
thank you casa shaughnessy uh thank you
berna good evening everyone present
thank you casa stills
good evening berna good evening everyone
present i think councillor morris has
now joined us
oh customaries
okay casper swain yes president vanna
thank you very much thank you chairman
thank you agenda item two
apologies for absence may i have the
apologies for absence please
we have no apologies for absence
chairman and i think yes cancer morris
has joined us
if he could just confirm that he can
hear us and
everything's working fine
okay that's fine let's carry on thank
you agenda item
three minutes 31st march 2021
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 31st of march
2021
found on pages 7-10 are approved and as
a true and accurate record
i so move and if you wish to second that
motion please remove your microphone and
state your name now
thank you if any member wishes to raise
any matter of accuracy please use the
hands up function to indicate
and i'll invite you to speak
cancer seances um thank you chairman
um it refers to page nine um
the 2001 essex road application
um at the time um of this meeting
i i didn't realize that i did know
um people that live either side of 21.
um i knew these people lived in essex
road but i
didn't know exactly where they were so i
would like some
um some um
you know what shall i do about this does
it need to be changed or or leave it as
it is
thank you berna can i ask you to
yes we we can put a note on the minutes
council shaughnessy to say subsequent to
the meeting
and we were advised of the following
and if you could just send me something
on an email a form of writing on an
email that would be fine
i'll do that berna thank you very much
thank you clairman thank you
thank you um
shall i go page by page or do you want
to all agree this by a sentence please
happy to agree bye
thank you item thank you item for
declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disposable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-vicunary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda coming
regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conflict from
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the handshop function there
to indicate
i normally invite you to speak
counsellor heard
uh thank you chairman i think we
probably all have an interest in this
because it's council owned land which is
why it's come to this uh
committee um but that's uh that's my
only declaration i'm sure we'll
follow suit on that thank you thank you
councillor
can you advise if any other member
wishes to speak no but as cancer
heard says we will be admitting it that
all members in attendance have
an interest thank you very much
can you not see my hand burner chair oh
sorry no
can't you remember my hand's not there
yes it is i can see it now all right so
thank you and yes i can have it
sorry it's popped up now thank you very
much
sorry yeah i concur with councillor
heard that in that you know we all
have an interest don't we because this
is um district council land so
i would say um uh that uh certain a
non-pecuniary interest
yes i just said that i would be noting
it on the minutes as a non-pecuniary
for all members in attendance thank you
thank you uh agenda item five
we've now moved to attend to item five
found on pages 11 to 22
and in a moment i will call on the
officer to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item
please make this known by using the
hands up function within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn and
please keep your points clear
and concise ms staplehurst please can
you present
your report thank you chairman
this application proposes a food and
drink kiosk
located at the crazy golf course within
the prom park
in malden there is a verbal update which
is that the
conservation officer has no objections
to the proposal and
so this is the uh application site
um you see this is a park drive
uh to the southwest here and the access
into the
prom park um and the crazy golf course
here it's important to note that the
original application for the golf course
um from 2014
included a proposed cafe within the
northern part
of the site here this permission was
implemented
as the um crazy golf course was built
however the cafe approved under that
application wasn't built
and to date hasn't been built however as
this permission is it is extant
the cafe could be built at any time
however it's now proposed to construct a
smaller timber kiosk instead
there have been two previous
applications on the site for
temporary food and drink structures
these were granted temporary missions
permissions only as they were mobile
structures and it was not considered
appropriate for the character of the
area
to allow them to be stationed permanent
this application is for a permanent
timber structure
which is more in keeping with the
character of the area
so these are the existing and proposed
block plan as you can see this is where
the
kiosk would be located along the western
boundary of the gold coast
these are the proposed elevations uh
showing the
entrance door for the start on the
northern side and the
two serving hatches on the front
and the floor plans
the photographs of the site looking
north and west
towards the position of the proposed
kiosk
and some photos of the view south again
towards the proposed location of the
kiosk
in conclusion the kiosk would be used in
conjunction with the existing crazy golf
course site
there are no objections in terms of
design or the impact on the character of
the area
and therefore they are caged before
approval
thank you chairman thank you
um before i open the debate
are there any other officers wishing to
comment
no okay i now open the debate and invite
you to put any questions we will make
any comments you have on this report
berna who has indicated that they wish
to speak
uh counselor head chairman i just yeah
um thank you chairman uh i i i take it
that uh there's no uh
uh ward members wishing to speak i i'll
i'll happily give way to
councillor swain i think it's his uh
area yes he's just put his hand up
council swain would you like to start
off as board member
you're muted that's okay chairman um
yes i wanted to clarify some points on
this
first um this is not the orientation of
the existing huts but on the
the well the road side so to speak as i
understand it the survey hatches on
the outside this presumably is
effectively
in place of some of the fencing along
that side
um so we'll be pleased to have more on
that
um but i i go back to that um
comment that uh the officer just made
about being in conjunction with the
crazy golf side
if it's just facing outwards um i don't
see how it really connects
with the crazy golf um
site and enterprise it would seem to me
it
ought to be much more closely linked to
that
and in which case it then ought to have
um some seating at least as it did
before when there was a temporary
up there so this looks like to me just
another these wayside
um takeaways similar to
most of the others uh are nothing
special i think
it needs to be more um integrated with
the
with the crazy gulf side um
and people there and open then to people
on the site and people from the
outside to come in to make it much more
of a
facility for um all
people in the park but
not in uh not in the same way as all the
other kiosks and i think we've got
we have to guard against having too many
of the same sort of thing
um when we really need something rather
different and it's a pity that
that original idea of a cafe was never
progressed because
that is the sort of thing which prom
part really needs
so i'm i'm not really um liking this
proposal because of the design and
layout of it
um i would prefer to be facing inwards
um to the area that the large area they
have that's unused
um and that be the area for people who
either seated or to have food to take
away
thank you thank you council slain uh
miss devilhouse are you able to answer
country sweden's questions
thank you chairman um i'll just call up
the plans
um so you can see it's it's shown on
sort of on the existing
decking area and they'd be sort of
decking to the
the front of the um kiosk here so it
would be
facing inwards uh towards the site
so towards the decking area so it
wouldn't be facing
sort of towards the road um
obviously people can still sort of
access
the site to sort of come in to use it
um but it would it would be facing
inwards from the plans
okay thank you very much that's that's
most important i think
okay thank you um council heard
um
thank you chairman um yes i think that's
uh
that's one point that uh that i also
wanted to make because i think we need
to make sure that there is a boundary
fence
behind this if this is an application to
go within
the golf the golf site um
and we and to make sure that it's
actually for
those people who are using that facility
that's how it's uh
kind of been been sold and not just yet
another one
um on the prom and i'd also
like to uh look at some conditions
uh in relation to advertising
uh but i i can come to those uh later on
but
um i i'm just like councillor swain i'm
just a bit concerned about
the way that it's facing if it is
enclosed within the golf site
uh then i'm content with it can we just
confirm that that is the case and that
it can't be accessed from the outside
through you chairman there is no um
plans to remove the boundary fence
that's already there they haven't
indicated that that's going to be
removed
so the fence will remain in place that's
good thank you
in that case then the only the only
other thing that i would like to see
is an extra condition added uh that
there should be
um no signs or adverts which are more
than 0.3
square meters or illuminated signed
affixed to the structure
i'd just like to add that as a condition
please thank you
um mr lee i think you wanted to answer
that
thank you chairman um
i can't remember the exact explicit
limitations on adverts signage um
there is though a requirement for any
sign that's
illuminated that's basically not on a
pharmacy to acquire advertisement
consent so
we wouldn't need to put a condition on
in relation to
illuminated lights because they would
need advertisement consent separately so
it's not necessary
um there may well be deemed permission
and i don't know the size of
the cuts i won't want to shoot from the
hip so if members did consider
that a condition in relation to limiting
advertisement
normally be deemed wouldn't require
advertisement consent was appropriate
i'd suggest that that was um agreed with
the chairman and yourself
councillor heard so rather than saying
explicit size now because
obviously if the size what you're saying
is larger than
what they could do without needing
planning permission advertisements they
need permission anyway so it wouldn't be
necessary
so if members do think uh an advert
condition is appropriate
i don't request it's delegated rather
than being decided right now
thank you chairman yes i'm happy for
that to be delegated chairman thank you
thank you council heard uh counselor
miss sorry
uh i think councillor lagan was behind
me yes thank you pardon cancer it's okay
i don't mind giving away councillor mays
ladies before gentlemen
thank thank you councillor lagan um i
hope i won't steal your thunder
um is this building ancillary to the
activities on this site that's
what my um concerns lie around
i've looked at this it's 6.1 by
uh 2.5 that's not small
what is deemed as light refreshments
well light refreshments to me is sort of
like tea and a biscuit maybe
maybe a coffee something like that
however this
is um uh there's got a panini grill a
griddle
two pan fryers soup four fridges four
fridges
uh freezer ice cream ice cream i would
expect ice cream to
to be there um so i'm not actually
feeling that this is an ancillary
activity
um it's an additional activity that is
going on
or always is planned going forward
um it is not offering anything different
to many of the other outlets
um so i'm a little concerned about that
um
i'm also concerned that about the the
flood zoning uh
and confused um ea says that it's flood
zone 3a
but i think in the report it comes back
as
possibly part of it's in 3a and part of
it is in
two um have any sequential tests been
done
and met i i can't find it but i might
have missed it in in the reports i
apologize for that
um uh 5.1.1 actually states that um
no retail impact assessment was done um
why why was this should this not have
been done
um what are the conditions or you know
what are the eligibilities around doing
any retail assessment
for an outlet like this um in the park
we need to be very careful what we are
allowing in the park and make sure it is
going to be the very very best
that we possibly can get for this
location it's high profile
thank you thank you uh council remains
um
[Music]
mr staplehurst can you answer some of
those questions or all of them uh
through you chairman
um yes so first of all in relation
to um in relation to the food that's
served
if i draw your attention to condition
eight and we have imposed the condition
um that says there shouldn't be any
primary cooking
um which is the application of heat to
raw or fresh food in order to cook it
initially um unless the scheme for
ventilation has been installed
um so but at the moment it is just sort
of take away
food and drinks cake sandwiches that
sort of thing that is proposed
um so no sort of hot food meals
that sort of thing at the moment um
relation to flood risk i'm just finding
the relevant
section on the report
5.5 yeah
yes thank you and so the the
eastern part of the wider site the golf
course site
is within a full zone um but the actual
area where the kiosk is located is just
outside of the flood zone so
as part of the site is in the flood zone
that's why
flood risk has been considered um but as
it the actual area where the kiosk will
be located
um isn't within the flood zone um
it's been sort of considered acceptable
that they have provided some information
in relation to flood risk and um
evacuation plans and that's been
included
uh in the conditions and so that's
that's indeed
considered to be suitable in relation to
um
then in relation to i think it was the
retail impact assessment that you
mentioned
um because the 2014 application
um sort of agreed the principle of
having
a cafe on the site and then there have
been two applications
since and to have temporary food and
drink structures on the site
and that sort of established the
principle of the development
of having this sort of development in
this location
and because if this wasn't if this
didn't take place they are
able to build the cafe that was approved
in 2014 which is a much larger
cafe thank you chairman
thank you yes i understood that as well
as the
that that planning approval
some years ago is extent in other words
that it can continue
correct my thinking on that
yes yes that's correct okay uh
cancer management come back on uh yeah
um you you say that um that that there's
likely to be takeaway
food and no hot food or meals could be
prepared um well pan fryers
is heating and cooking chips um
you have to eat soup yeah you have to
take you have to eat
tea and coffee um i i'm i think this is
going to be just more than
what i call a coffee and cake stop um
whilst perhaps your
your young people are enjoying
themselves on the crazy golf which is
what i do
um and and i'm not entirely happy with
uh the the the overall use and size
of this building i don't think it's
gonna look very pretty either um i don't
see that it will fit in with the
parkland um situation
i'm also not terribly happy with the uh
the fact that nothing has actually been
done and that there is extant permission
here well that might
well be the case but why are we now
um being asked to approve this one why
can't they just use the extant
permission sorry i don't understand that
if anyone can help me
mr johnson did you want to come in on
there
yes um yes um i understand um
councilman's points but um the the
starting point for us
on this particular site given that there
is that history
there is a the wider development which
has been implemented
that included a cafe type structure
which could provide a range of foods as
was mentioned by my colleague
miss staplehurst um they hadn't
implemented it there'd been a series of
temporary permissions as was said
already um agreeing the principle
of something similar to what's proposed
here although a temporary
type of structure hence the temporary
permissions for those
and they were advised to come up with
something permanent so really when we
look at the timeline when we look at the
context and we look at the history
when we look at what they can build um
in our view this is this is perfectly
reasonable
um the range of foods that they've
provided
is reasonable again within that context
we're putting out conditions to make
sure that they
they don't carry out an excessive amount
of deep fat frying
uh and the sort of foods that could uh
really give a sort of pungent smell
without without any source of control
and probably may not even be suitable
for that type of structure
so from a planning point of view one is
reasonable
um uh the conditions themselves are
reasonable in that sense
um so therefore we feel it's is
satisfactory
uh it may be a different design they're
at liberty to come and change
the design they're not necessarily
wedded to the design that was proposed
previously
their model has changed from what we've
understood and that's acceptable thank
you
thank you mr johnson i think can we go
back to
cancer laggard now i think are you there
yeah thank you yeah i'm there so i'm
having a bit of bandwidth travel tonight
chair and members
members of the public offices
um so just to um to clarify a couple of
points from me um i'll ask a couple of
questions and make a comment if i may
share
the first though the first thing is that
is there any legal reason why this
development can't go ahead
i'm sorry counselor do you mean indeed
well i think yeah
yeah so with with this plan with
what did what the um applicant has
actually put in for us is there any
reason why we shouldn't go ahead with
this
um i'm still not quite sure counselor um
lagging but i mean we're recommending
this for approval we feel like
it's followed it's followed a a planning
a planning timeline and
a planning precedent if you want to put
it in that sense
um it'd be a less intense development
than what could
be carried out if they were to implement
the permission and it's for i wish
they're at liberty to do that because
obviously it had commenced because the
wider development had commenced and
there's ton there's no timeline for them
to
actually finish the development in a
sense
um so they can carry out as and when
okay beautiful that's very elegant i'll
say thank you
michael um the second funnies that from
a perspective of
how i look at it is um the
have the applications been put in and
it's been there's been an approval for a
caf there
um i believe the the design is the same
as what the administration
area and the entrance part is so it's
it's a matching facility
it's a box type of design in essence
isn't it
but the um building if it gets
permission to go ahead um
it is in keeping with the toilet
block which is opposite with a nice
beautiful on the wall that makes the
the carbuncle of the toilet look a lot
nicer so from a perspective
of really um
they're allowed to go ahead with that i
don't mind them particularly having that
facility there to support families
um and that that should for me sort of
finish the the food
and joints on on the prom because we've
got enough of them
and i'd be happy to support this thank
you
thank you cancer legend uh cancer stops
i think you're waiting there
thank you mr chairman um the question
for louise when you look at the
um plans um they show this
um kiosk that's going to be built when
you look at the photographs they show
two more structures um and some rubbish
are those structures staying because
they're actually not on the plans
they don't show them or are they going
to remove those structures
three youth chairman um they they aren't
shown on the plans
um and they aren't a part of the
application
um that's something that is sort of
outside of the scope of
this that application
we have to would have to be um sort of
either through
enforcement and also questioning the
agent to see what they are for
okay um council hood
thank you jim i'm sorry to have a second
bite at cherry but i just wanted to
uh just to clarify so what we're talking
about is
one food outlet uh
on this uh so this will take
uh the place of the proposed cafeteria
so there shouldn't be a second
application coming along on this
um i'm just a little bit concerned about
mr johnson's comment about them not
being wedded to the design
uh what i wouldn't want to see is some
gaudy misshapen
uh shed put up there which is uh meant
to be kind of pirate-like it's supposed
to be
uh similar to the design that we're
approving
um so that's really what uh maybe he can
uh um just clarify that please
thank you mr johnson oh yes
yes um thank you chair um sorry
counselor heard that that's not what i
meant
um i i didn't mean that they could um we
would grant permission
uh for this uh structure if that were to
be the case
and then they build something else i
just meant wedded to the design in the
sense of
um responding to councillor may's
comments
about the fact that they had permission
for a previous building but the model
had changed over the years
so my comments was in that context not
in terms of this
if permission were to be granted it
would be for the development as on the
plans
and they couldn't come along and change
that so just just as for clarity
i have every confidence in you mr
johnson okay thank you thank you thank
you
uh cancer nun uh yes through you
chair if um councillor lagan is still
there
um is councillor lagan making
his point as a proposal
yeah i can propose that and council
answer to
to to support the officer's
recommendation
through the chat yes thank you
councillor lagan and through through you
then chair i'd like to second that
proposal
well thank you cancer and that was
actually going to be my next uh
next question so thank you so that is
now proposed and seconded
and um now we can uh
take the vote or would you like to agree
the recommendation for a prose
approval sorry cancer seance
has her hands up thank you pardon me
thank you for that that's that's fine
chairman thank you very much
um reading through all this today i
understand it
is that should this be um
agreed this evening the snack bar
then they are still able to um
put in an application for the cafe as
well
as it is extang extant i would like
clarification on that
please thank you
um mr johnson oh
this devil has can you well i think if
miss staplehurst can um
can show where the sighting of the
previous cafe is are you able to do that
louise and compared to this proposal um
i
uh through you chairman i don't have the
plans from the
2000 cafe it's positioned in a it's
larger but it is in the same location as
this proposal so if this was built they
wouldn't be able to build the cafe as
well
this would have to be removed for the
cafe to be built thank you chairman okay
thank you for that clarification and
thank you chairman
thank you okay it's uh uh
recommendation for approval has been
proposed and
i'm sorry counselor did you want to is
that hand's gone
and he's been seconded by councillor nun
so would you like to take
do we need to take a vote um by ascend
or
so sorry can i just yeah just just to
clarify
yeah i just wanted um just mistaken her
just to clarify that that
last point again about um
the priebus cafe
uh the previously approved cafe is
uh isn't as the same location as this
kiosk
but the kiosk is smaller than what the
cafe was previously
approved so they wouldn't both be able
to be built at the same time
right so just we're confirming that it
would be in the same location
as the previously approved cap yes
right okay thank you okay
recorded vote please a recorded vote
please yeah i would i would second that
mr chairman councilmembers
okay uh berna can you do that and take
the recording vote please
clarity chairman with or without council
heard suggested additional condition
when we have the amendment on
screenplays
can you do that thank you
if you do who's off and i'm coughing
dude chairman i'm not sure we can have
it on screen because the whole point was
it was delegated
delegation yes chairman that's what i
was just
about to clarify that we agreed that it
would be the issue around advertisements
would be delegated
to officers in consultation with the
chairman and members oh yeah yes
yeah thank your pardon
but can we still have the roll call then
uh please yes of course chairman thank
you very much
members i will call your names in
alphabetical order can you please state
clearly
for against abstain we're voting for the
officer's recommendation to approve
the application as detail sorry subject
to the conditions as detailed
in section 8 of the report and also the
condition
as outlined by councillor heard uh
delegated to officers in consultation
with the chairman
and members thank you miss phil
thank you councillor edwards
against
shaughnessy against
asl stilts against
mr swain
thank you members chairman that's six
for the
approval for against no abstentions
thank you therefore this um
application has been approved thank you
um i have no other items of business so
i close this meeting
at 6 40 and thank you very much for with
officers and members attending
and any members of the public
thank you